[Music]
it's the Lord's Day [ __ ] not the
boot pom [ __ ] Sunday for most
Gentiles they're waving a pom around for
me I got my hand out it's pump [ __ ]
Sunday you got to get out there and
[ __ ] get that twenty that's fifty
whatever you need to make it happen I
don't know about you guys but I hope
you're ready we're going pilot to
Bombardier pilot to Bombardier it's
gonna be the one of those types of spark
sessions so get ready oh yeah you bad
[ __ ]
uncle Joey finally showed up you guys
like Papa way you've been kicking the
door waving the for for oh you're her
was Papa don't hit me no more there you
go there you go it's that time
[ __ ] Jeff Sessions way ya [ __ ]
this is the weed that Jeff session
smoked well he said [ __ ] it
we ain't that bad what's happening you
bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here lookin
like Jimmy Palumbo on st. Nicholas
Avenue 100 and [ __ ] don't worry about
it Street I hope you're here we're here
it's Palm Sunday to all the Catholics
too [ __ ] savages like me we gotta go
out and put some in the [ __ ] Palmer
yardstick whatever a [ __ ] hit or
something and that's the way it's gonna
be I love you [ __ ] I haven't
seen you all week I was in New York I
got caught nor'easter he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
half of eggs a little bit of snow right
away they gotta give it a name to scare
white people it was alright
I had reef I came prepared I had edibles
you know me dog up that briefcase I got
a stuffed with [ __ ] I'll never get bored
in the hotel room I never watched Law &
Order [ __ ] sober anyway we're here
with quiz 220 [ __ ] whatever March and
here you are still [ __ ] around I got
a beautiful [ __ ] day lined up
I'm still high from last night
I ain't gonna lie to you had a couple
spots last night I came home I got
[ __ ] up jack till about 11:45 I was
tweeting and [ __ ] let your [ __ ]
know what's going on it's gonna be a
good week we had two great podcasts at
five o'clock today Michael Rapaport Nick
doctoral and we're getting sponsored by
Buscemi sandwiches out in Beverly Hills
the [ __ ] best you follow me so tune
in number one I gotta go get a [ __ ]
juice over at the greenhouse I don't
like this [ __ ] I'm gonna get a nice
[ __ ] kale pineapple [ __ ] coconut
juice because the pineapple [ __ ] the
juice is good for the muscles for
recuperation and I'm an old man I'm
trying to put the [ __ ] pieces
together you follow me
I gotta stop at the bank I gotta stop to
see my favorite people son chatter but
they [ __ ] around listen if you want
to get stoned you gotta go to Sunset
horrible I think I've some [ __ ] called
og sunset that I'm [ __ ] Joey
which would be a beat if I want an
information guide had [ __ ] go down to
the airport enough all right I smoked a
[ __ ] couple balls in and we'll get
the temptation started tremendous I got
this mother [ __ ] King Louie it was so
good the label almost god I'm fine by
itself oh [ __ ] there you go this King
Louie will [ __ ] you up I'm telling you
right now they don't know what's
cracking tonight but we got the weed
that [ __ ] and killed everybody Stephen
Hawkins was killed everybody
like I said is the best part of my week
when we get together on Sunday like the
Waltons you know I'm saying we get
together we don't eat but we smoke which
was a it's a stronger [ __ ] bond of
untrusted Church I want to give my
condolences and the church family
condolences to my grow Cleo
she lost a father over the weekend if
you know Cleo from tour to give us some
[ __ ] love but I reached my heart out
to her hand the Church of what's
happened now it's hard to let you know
that Cleo is one of us have you heard we
[ __ ] hurt so our heart goes out to
you beside that it's another week
[ __ ] and you're on a mission to
do what uncle Joey you're on a mission
to be a better you you don't give a [ __ ]
whatever happened last week you shot
that heroin on Thursday [ __ ] it this
week you're gonna go without pH maybe
you eat a cup of [ __ ] pot cookies or
a xanax but you didn't do the H and
that's all that's not matters at the end
of week that's how you beat that [ __ ]
addiction I beat it I smoked some weed
now all I did was a transfer to addition
to wheat but I've always smoked weed you
know I'm saying but what am i a [ __ ]
counselor who gives a [ __ ] I want you
guys to be happy that's all that [ __ ]
matters
you worry too much you worry about this
you worry about that bet you there ain't
no debtors prison you just keep moving
straight and you'll see all the pieces
fall into [ __ ] place you follow me
but Joey let's keep smoking ain't going
nowhere I ain't going no way you see me
tapping [ __ ]
I'm just getting the [ __ ] poker at
death that doubles as a [ __ ] shish
kebab stick there's some time to time
you gotta run with these people a shish
kebab stick as it's run this [ __ ]
weapon and and what we talking about
weapons it's a no violence Sunday it's
the Lord's Day Jeff Sessions where you
at we still got the [ __ ] yell of debt
there you go another one down but there
we go we always gotta back them you
always got to back up for the back up
for the back up you follow me I don't
even know what this is this is I can't
see without my glasses I'm getting old
people but what are you gonna do well
you want me to tap back cuz they I get
[ __ ] 10% off at Denny's no 55 they
could shove their tempers on up their
ass I got dignity you understand me I'd
taken a temper son said sherbert Oh
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] around open
from 6 to [ __ ] 10 in them at night
listen who does this type of thing why
people too busy on a Sunday for going to
the yard not the Russians are open 10 6
a.m. to 10 why it's the [ __ ]
immigrant mentality we don't stop we
ain't got time to figure out the you
bribe we just jump out in front of the
cab and go hey what the [ __ ] you go hey
taking you back at your country you
can't leave now
yeah stop at the bank area my [ __ ]
juice my healthy juice then I'm not
gonna see the Russians and I'm gonna go
to so I can play Dayton dose of you're
the dad's with some edibles you know how
we do and then I got the [ __ ] podcast
and then we got a few [ __ ] spots
tonight so for your [ __ ] the
tank that you know everybody's out here
just Fanning their balls jumping up and
down that's [ __ ] you got to work
every day every day 27 years I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm relentless you
understand me I'm relentless because at
the end of the day ain't nobody there at
the supermarket when you're gonna check
out to pay your [ __ ] bills so get
your [ __ ] together stop with the jumping
up and down cuz I ain't that much of a
party studio 54 closed in [ __ ] 86 or
five whatever and that's where then you
[ __ ] will try to recreate it's
too late but VIP service something like
that VIP services when you got to
[ __ ] chicks licking your ass on your
doing online a [ __ ] coke that's VIP
service if you ain't getting that stay
home and mind your business
anyway like I told you know I'm no Swami
from salami I just know this for a fact
it's gonna be a good week write your
goals believe in what you believe and
don't let nobody stop you because at the
end of the day they can all suck your
dick I gotta suck your dick
believe in you if you have that little
feeling that I think I can do this go
for it smoke a joint get a notebook
write out you're planning a [ __ ]
attack and go after these [ __ ]
one by one you know follow me like John
wick one by one anyway I got [ __ ] to do
and people to see Santa Ana casino this
sold the [ __ ] out I got next Saturday
night at the ice house working out with
uncle Joey Tuesday 9:00 9:30 at the
Comedy Store if you're around you know I
don't ask you for not in the church I
need you at the store tip top in the
original boom buy the tickets right now
Netflix is coming down and I got to show
them what the church love is all about
you follow me they don't know they don't
know what we got they don't know that me
and you are together they don't know
that we're [ __ ] we're bigger than a
crime family cuz when I'm motivated by
greed were motivated by [ __ ] love we
don't give a [ __ ] jack all we want is
the best for you and you're the best for
me and that's how the party starts if
you're not leaving the house thinking
that way there's two places I don't
think about them but why how I gotta
make somebody's day and number two who's
gonna smoke my [ __ ] dick today
actually you got to think about when you
leave the [ __ ] house and I mean that
a couple different ways look that
somebody's gonna be sucking you dick
like a perv but you walking around only
Carli Weinstein I'm talking about that
somebody's on the stuff you dick you're
gonna conquer somebody today you're
gonna sell something you're gonna put
somebody together most importantly
you're gonna come home because you play
for [ __ ] keeps you follow me
what anyway now that you [ __ ] savages
got me all wired up let's do one more
what the [ __ ] were you going what do you
guys that's going on with your [ __ ]
life nothing so sit sit tight
there's Jankel Joey talking to you oh I
miss Ohio 419 420 to 421 if you don't
think that [ __ ] be sold out
with a bunch of savages you're wrong so
if I was you get your [ __ ] tickets
cuz for 20 we read edibles on stage
we're going to jail in Columbus we're
serving a stint at the 90-day Columbus
Correctional Facility just not a [ __ ]
principal coz we don't give a [ __ ] you
follow me anyway you woke up I'm ready
to go I'm ready to go Netflix wants it
you guys made it happen that's why I
love you guys with all my heart that's
why I do the two podcast that's why I do
these things
it's not about the dollars it's in the
sense it's keeping in touch at you
[ __ ] savages is putting you together
so when you go out there nobody can tell
you nothing you follow me
[ __ ] along
anyway that's it and that's that
I'll see you [ __ ] Saturday
night his house 9:30 working out what
uncle Joey we're putting together this
[ __ ] Netflix weapon thing Tuesday
night if you ain't doing none you know I
don't ask you for nothing it's gonna be
a superb lineup anyway I go up at 9:30
and what comes after me is gonna be
[ __ ] the hell a [ __ ] don't like the
comedy store is it's a [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] and that's that that that's a
long as you're the [ __ ] actors you of
comics we don't give a [ __ ] with
criminals were [ __ ] intellectuals
we'll God we don't [ __ ] around we take
it to the next level so anyway I hope
you have a great day with your family
hug them or tell them or you love them I
remember two most important things in
life you gotta make somebody's day and
number two when you leave the house
who's gonna smoke your nutsack that day
on a [ __ ] daily oh yeah they didn't
get my mother I bingo I do you tell
illegal you are sanic or you're so evil
awesome you see mark I rally for you but
I'll I miss it so whatever you gotta do
you gotta [ __ ] do alright don't
forget go out there and be strong make
eye contact and remember at the end of
the day they all kind of SoCal I mean I
love you [ __ ] see you at 5
o'clock the Church of what's happening
now [ __ ]
then to the plane pilot to Bombardier